Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
"﻿Ci svegliamo, ed è cambiato il mondo."
"Svegliamoci, il mondo è cambiato!"
"Svegliamoci, e cambiamo il mondo."
Sono tre frasi che usano
esattamente le stesse parole
con significati e toni molto diversi.
Le parole sono: il risveglio, ovviamente,
qui; il mondo; e il suo cambiamento.
Io voglio parlarvi di cambiamento.
Non siamo abituati al cambiamento.
Siamo adatti al cambiamento?
Non siamo adatti al cambiamento;
come organismi viventi,
tendiamo all'equilibrio.
Qualsiasi cosa
che modifichi il nostro stato
ci fa dissipare energia
per raggiungere di nuovo un equilibrio.
Come operatori economici,
il nostro destino
è quello di manipolare
i fattori produttivi
per ottenere un tornaconto.
Ogni modifica dei fattori produttivi
o del contesto è un guaio:
ci costringe a lavorare,
convincere delle persone,
riportarci in equilibrio;
e forse riotterremo un tornaconto.
E poi siamo europei, italiani, mantovani,
viviamo in uno dei territori
dove si vive meglio al mondo.
Se il povero Steve Jobs
fosse qui, e ci guardasse,
non direbbe: “Stay hungry”.
Io no sicuramente, e penso neanche voi.
(Risate)
Quindi non è quella,
la molla che ci porta al cambiamento.
Ma di che cambiamento parliamo?
Parliamo - ci sono due autori:
Friedman è un giornalista americano,
di quelli che vanno in giro
a intervistare le persone
che contano, per il mondo.
E Teller è la persona
che ha il budget di ricerca
più grande del mondo,
è il detentore del budget
di ricerca di Google.
Sono concordi che esista un livello
molto alto del cambiamento
che loro chiamano
"cambiamento di alta quota",
caratterizzato da tre linee
parallele del discorso.
La prima linea è naturale:
si chiama cambiamento climatico,
abbiamo sentito la pioggia, poco fa.
Il secondo è la seconda linea:
il cambiamento sociale, si chiama
la globalizzazione delle persone.
Dopo la globalizzazione delle merci,
stiamo attraversando la fase
di una accelerata
globalizzazione delle persone.
Ci sono, in questo momento,
350 milioni di persone
che si stanno muovendo
dal luogo in cui sono nate o cresciute.
Ce ne rendiamo poco conto,
forse perché il 92% si muove
all'interno dello stesso continente.
E poi la terza linea di cambiamento:
è il cambiamento tecnologico,
la legge di Moore.
Sono 18-20 anni
che ogni due anni raddoppiamo
la nostra capacità di processare dati.
Abbiamo una capacità
e una velocità di processare dati
enormemente più alta di quella
che riusciamo ad utilizzare.
Questi dicevamo, però,
sono i cambiamenti di alta quota.
Ma vicino a noi, sulla pelle
dove sentiamo le gocce d'acqua,
dove sentiamo freddo,
c'è un altro tipo di cambiamento.
Il primo fattore di questo cambiamento
potremmo dire che è la velocità.
La velocità è importantissima,
perché ci stiamo rendendo conto
che se andiamo più veloce
di quello che la velocità ci chiede,
ci fracassiamo.
Commettiamo errori con più facilità.
Non ce la facciamo più, ad andare
più veloci di come stiamo andando.
È molto probabile
che la risposta alla velocità
sia la continuità.
La continuità è un fattore
che ci costringe
a riorganizzarci completamente,
a cambiare i nostri set
mentali e organizzativi,
quotidiani e a lungo termine.
Cerchiamo di capirci meglio:
quando siete in un hotel,
e aprite il rubinetto dell'acqua calda,
arriva subito l'acqua calda.
A casa mia, con il boiler a nove metri,
ci mette un po’ più di tempo.
Perché?
Perché in un hotel,
o in un luogo pubblico di quel tipo,
esiste un circuito di acqua
che tiene continuamente
in movimento l'acqua calda,
per cui l'acqua calda scorre
a pochi centimetri dal rubinetto,
e quando lo aprite risponde.
Ecco, provate ad immaginare
la vostra organizzazione, la vostra vita
come se tenessimo continuamente
in movimento questo sistema;
per esempio, lo sa bene
chi deve fare innovazione.
Se tu cominci a fare ricerca
nel momento in cui il mercato ti chiede
una risposta, un prodotto o un servizio,
non ce la fai!
Nessuno ti dà più il tempo
di fare quello che hai bisogno di fare.
Nessuno, non c'è più il tempo.
O sei già in movimento,
o ti sei fatto le domande
quando nessuno ti faceva le domande;
oppure, se l'iniziativa
arriva dal marketing,
vuol dire che qualcuno,
tra i tuoi clienti,
ha già visto un qualche cosa
fatto da qualcun altro,
ed è troppo tardi.
La seconda caratteristica importante
è l'autorialità,
perché noi siamo cresciuti in un mondo
in cui si dà un grandissimo valore
al genio individuale,
all'uomo della provvidenza.
Le soluzioni arrivano
perché qualcuno,
a un certo punto, ci pensa
ed è dotato per risolverlo.
Quando sappiamo, scientificamente,
che l'intelligenza collettiva
è enormemente più potente
di qualsiasi singolo genio.
Il terzo elemento è legato
alla non illimitatezza delle risorse.
Siamo nati e cresciuti,
parlo per la mia generazione soprattutto,
abbiamo visto il filmato precedente,
pensando che tutto quanto
sarà a nostra disposizione per sempre.
E ci troviamo a lavorare, invece,
in un circuito, in un sistema
in cui tutti gli output,
tutto quello che noi scartiamo
deve essere reimmesso
dentro un altro sistema come input.
Ogni output deve diventare un input.
Economia circolare,
chiamatela come volete, System Design.
Anche questo ci cambia nettamente
il quadro in cui operiamo.
E poi, siamo cresciuti in una situazione
in cui i saperi sono blindati -
si dice - in silos.
Io mi occupo di un settore,
guai se invado il settore del vicino, no?
Ma pensate che in un'azienda
le chiamiamo divisioni.
Più chiaro di così,
gli abbiamo dato anche il nome giusto!
Per cui sapete che uno
non parla con l'altro;
e se parla,
non parlano la stessa lingua,
non si capiscono.
Ecco, noi scopriamo
che le cose più interessanti
arrivano, negli ultimi tempi,
dal crossing tra più saperi:
le neuroscienze e le biotecnologie
sono sempre situazioni
in cui ci si incontra e ci si scambia,
o si guardano i fenomeni
con più punti di vista.
E poi il prodotto!
Noi siamo un - permettetemi:
il Made in Italy, la cultura del prodotto.
Noi sappiamo valutare al tatto, al fiuto,
al sapore, al gusto, alla vista,
anche da distante la qualità delle cose.
Abbiamo, rispetto alla media globale,
una cultura del prodotto molto alta.
Peccato che è il momento
in cui ha molta importanza
la qualità del processo.
La qualità del processo è diventata
importantissima, ce ne siamo accorti.
C'è un Canale 52,
che qualcuno di voi, sono convinto,
lo guarda, e io lo guardo,
che trasmette
come si produce la marmellata,
come si fanno gli pneumatici.
Cose di questo tipo;
pensate che è un broadcasting americano
tradotto in 27 lingue,
lo guardano 850 milioni
di persone al mondo
per almeno quattro ore alla settimana.
Cosa se ne faranno di tutta questa cultura
sulla fabbricazione degli pneumatici?
Eppure è una passione, no?
Io ho visto una trasmissione, due anni fa,
in cui a Report mostravano
come si strappava il piumino delle oche
e le oche non felici, che non donavano
volontariamente questo piumino.
Il giorno dopo, alla Borsa di New York,
questa impresa ha perso 180 milioni
di dollari di capitalizzazione.
Ho passato la mia prima parte
della mia vita
con mia mamma che mi diceva: compralo,
controlla però che ci sia il piumino!
E la seconda parte della mia vita
con mia moglie che dice:
sei pazzo, sei un maiale!
Hai comprato una roba
con dentro il piumino!
Non so più cosa comprare.
(Risate)
E poi le questioni materiali,
le cose materiali,
noi siamo cresciuti nel materiale.
Siamo in un mondo in cui
o ci occupiamo delle cose materiali,
perché abbiamo un corpo,
o ci occupiamo delle cose digitali.
Eppure ci troviamo a vivere e lavorare
in un mondo che si è accorto
che tutto ciò che è materiale
deve avere un gemello digitale,
sennò non esiste.
Ma tutto ciò che è digitale,
deve avere un gemello materiale.
Il gemello materiale è fondamentale,
lo sa Amazon che era, forse,
l'unico operatore economico mondiale
che poteva fare a meno
di comparire sulla scena,
e sta cercando di aprire
negozi fisici in tutto il mondo.
È fondamentale, abbiamo un corpo;
se tu stai nel digitale,
non compari ai nostri sensi, non esisti.
E poi, ancora, la privacy.
La privacy: ci stanno spiando,
state attenti. State attenti, no?
Eravamo convinti che le nostre cose
le sapevamo forse noi e qualche amico.
No, le nostre cose
sono di dominio mondiale
e di dominio globale -
le sanno tutti tranne noi, forse.
(Risate)
Quindi, immaginate in un mondo
in cui l'informazione
è il bene principale,
le nostre informazioni le sanno, tutte,
o le usano quelli che vogliono.
Ecco questo cambiamento è impetuoso,
ha a che fare con la nostra
capacità di affrontarlo
e con la nostra capacità di gestire
una cosa che chiamiamo anticipazione.
Sono le future sciences,
sono tanti studiosi
da molte discipline diverse
che da diversi decenni studiano il futuro
come se fosse un fenomeno scientifico.
E alcune indicazioni ce le possono dare.
Andiamo molto velocemente.
La prima informazione che ci danno
forse la sapevamo:
Il futuro non si può prevedere.
Dicono, si può costruire. Interessante.
La seconda informazione che ci danno
è che del futuro
noi conosciamo delle porzioni.
Immaginatevi una torta;
alcune fette noi le possediamo.
Le fette si chiamano costanti.
Se l'uomo è sulla Terra -
diciamo da un punto di vista cognitivo-
da 250.000 anni,
e si comporta in certi modi
questo significa
che probabilmente, domani,
non so cosa dovrebbe succedere
per modificare il nostro comportamento.
Quindi, attraverso lo studio
delle costanti -
se ne occupa l'antropologia -
noi abbiamo delle porzioni di certezza.
Poi abbiamo dati quantitativi
su ogni cosa: demografia, clima - tutto.
Dal 1500, negli archivi parrocchiali
del mondo cristiano
c'è scritto il nome dei nati,
quando sono nati, quando sono morti,
quando si sono sposati,
quando si sono battezzati eccetera.
Immaginatevi che mole di dati abbiamo
e che ci permettono di fare delle curve
e di avere un'ambizione di prospettiva.
Poi abbiamo i dati qualitativi: il trend.
La moda vive di trend,
sappiamo che colore andrà
il prossimo anno.
Sapete che quest'anno è il coral, no?
L'anno prossimo lo sappiamo già.
Quindi, immaginatevi quanti dati abbiamo,
sia qualitativi sia quantitativi.
E poi abbiamo i latenti,
che è una parola un po’ difficile per noi.
Li chiamavamo - nel nostro mondo,
il mondo del design della moda,
li chiamavamo i segnali deboli.
I segnali deboli sono qualcosa
che è già nel presente,
ma è portatore di futuro.
Immaginatevi che il tempo
sia questa cosa qua.
Questo è il passato, e questo è il futuro.
Noi siamo nel presente, lo tagliamo qua.
Cos'è il presente?
Il presente è la permanenza
di alcuni elementi del passato,
vedete le mie dita
che si rimpiccioliscono,
e l'inizio di alcuni fattori
che fanno già parte del futuro.
E quindi, studiando e togliendo
gli elementi del passato,
ci rimane una porzione di futuro.
Se la analizziamo rispetto
alla dinamica che sta avendo,
alla diffusione, a come cresce,
possiamo già avere in mano degli elementi
che ci permettono di studiare il futuro.
E poi, ci dicono ancora
quelli delle future sciences,
che il futuro singolare non esiste;
esistono i futuri.
I futuri sono tanti,
e sono in competizione per succedere.
Quindi noi dobbiamo
lavorare di scenaristica,
per capire come adattarci
ai vari futuri che potrebbero succedere.
Per esempio, poi, ci dice
che il futuro è un fatto collettivo.
Collettivo!
Quante più persone
noi riusciamo a convincere
che quel futuro,
che è auspicabile per noi,
sarà auspicabile anche per loro,
tanto più è probabile
che quel futuro si avveri.
Lo sa un bambino
che vuole andare allo stadio;
comincia ad ammorbare il padre,
poi lo zio, poi la madre,
la sorella, la cugina della cognata -
Quante più persone riesce a coinvolgere,
quanto più è probabile
che verrà portato allo stadio.
E quindi il futuro, ricordiamoci,
è un fatto collettivo.
E poi, il futuro inizia nel presente:
quindi, l'azione che commettiamo oggi
è una porzione importante
di quello che succederà domani.
Abbiamo visto anche con la carta igienica.
Poi, il futuro contiene
degli atteggiamenti.
Noi abbiamo degli atteggiamenti,
rispetto al futuro: sono quattro.
Primo atteggiamento,
in cui noi italiani siamo bravissimi,
i più grandi del mondo.
Si chiama atteggiamento urgente.
È già successo un patatrac,
un qualche cosa.
Forza, tutti, accorriamo
a mettere un riparo alla cosa.
La famosa pezza.
Penso che proprio l'abbiamo inventata noi.
Avessimo il brevetto della pezza
saremmo ricchissimi, no?
Poi c'è un secondo atteggiamento,
che si chiama emergente.
Vuol dire che stanno succedendo
alcuni elementi;
se li teniamo sotto controllo
sono portatori di qualcosa
che sta succedendo,
e quindi cominciamo a intervenire.
Il terzo comportamento
si chiama preattivo.
Non sta succedendo niente,
ma qualcosa succederà.
Quindi io comincio a prefigurarmi -
si chiamano proprio scenari- degli scenari
e a studiare come posso comportarmi
nell'ipotesi che qualcuno
di questi scenari si avveri.
E posso farlo sia per contrastarli,
che per farli succedere
se mi sono propizi.
Il quarto atteggiamento
si chiama proattivo.
Ed è proprio l'azione
del mettere energia, dell'investire
affinché quelli propizi si avverino
e quelli non propizi non si avverino.
E poi un altro ultimo elemento,
su cui la futurologia
e le future sciences, l'anticipazione,
ci portano a riflettere,
e che è molto importante,
per riuscire a lavorare sul domani,
che di solito è il tempo che ci interessa
non il domani-domani,
inteso proprio nel domani, il 26,
ma domani nel mondo del marketing:
l'anno prossimo, la prossima collezione,
la prossima stagione,
il prodotto che porterò in fiera,
e le vacanze che devo organizzare.
Ecco: per capire se il domani è giusto,
io devo studiare il dopodomani.
Perché è il dopodomani
che mi dà la direzione.
Se una persona vi incontra
e vi dice: “Sto andando giusto?”
Dovete come minimo chiedergli:
“Dipende dove vuoi arrivare”, no?
E quindi le parole profetiche
di due grandi italiani,
che erano Totò e Peppino che dicevano:
“Volevam savuar, noio volevan savuar,
per andare dove dobbiamo andare,
dove dobbiamo andare?”
contenevano già in essere questa profezia.
Cioè: se non sappiamo
dove dobbiamo andare,
come facciamo a scegliere
la strada per arrivarci?
Grazie della vostra attenzione.
(Applausi)